tens of thousands of venezuelans have
attended
rival rallies in a political standoff
with no resolution
in sight parliamentary leader and
self-declared interim president juan
guay doe
called on supporters to stay in the
streets
until sitting president nicolas maduro
steps down
but maduro still enjoys strong support
from his base
which celebrated the 20th anniversary of
coming to power
one guido's message to supporters is
that change is around the corner
he and his backers are demanding fresh
presidential elections
some who came out to support the
opposition leader say
even basic survival has become a
struggle
[Applause]
it's very difficult and getting worse
all the time
but since november the situation's been
out of control
i can't get hold of my blood pressure
medication anywhere
and it used to be the cheapest on the
market
now we can't get hold of even the most
basic painkillers
guido has garnered international backing
for his claim to be acting president
venezuela's sitting president maduro has
a key source of support in venezuela's
military leaders
but in a surprise move a high-ranking
commander in the air force
threw his support behind guido via
twitter on saturday
i'm addressing you today to let you know
that i reject the illegitimate and
dictatorial authority of mr nicolas
maduro
ninety percent of the armed forces
oppose the dictator and support the
venezuelan people
but maduro's backers also held rallies
marking 20 years since the rise to power
of late leader hugo chavez
maduro addressed the rally and suggested
holding congressional elections
earlier than planned but he remained
defiant
the opposition are tricking people in
venezuela saying they're in government
and that the entire country
and the armed forces obey them trickery
trickery
and more trickery
the crisis has split not only venezuela
itself
but with washington and the european
parliament backing guido
and russia and china supporting maduro
the split goes far beyond the south
american nation
[Music]
well for more i'm joined in the studio
by eduardo mendes from dw latin america
eduardo good morning to you so president
maduro
just announced that he's willing to hold
congressional elections
earlier than expected or then planned
so will this satisfy his critics
actually not what he's trying to do is
to gain some time
he's emulating some kind of democracy
but was
really clear his time is running out as
far as
the ultimatum from the eu concerns
and the simulation of democracy it just
won't work because
if you look at the constitution of
venezuela what what
one way god did is he is now the interim
president as far as the constitution
concerns and so this gaining of time
works maybe only for for some blind
leftists trying to see some democracy in
all of this but there's none
well what seems to be key to whether
madura manages
to hold on to power is the support of
the military
and just yesterday uh we heard a
venezuelan air force general
declaring his support for the opposition
leader awan guido
so is this the beginning of the end for
maduro well honestly we
we cannot know it's just a poke game
maduro has the military this was uh one
command
without troops and so it's more
of a sign but it's peace is falling
falling down from
from his regime and uh what
is trying to is to get support from the
military that's very decessive
it's very important if this humanitarian
aid is coming how the military will
behave
but huedo has no power he is just a
transitional piece
hopefully he's just transitional
according to the constitution
and maduro is holding on to the military
in the military still
holding on to maduro if you saw this
protest we have seen the pictures right
now
you see in in the supporting of maduro
lots of military this are commanded
troops going to
this uh demonstrations
so there's no real people backing maduro
you have some
measure on how much support he has and
it's about 15 20
so all right well 15 20 percent and the
military
is also significant um can you help us
understand
why maduro continues to enjoy all the
support from the army and from this 15
or 20
despite the awful economic crisis in
venezuela people
not having access to enough food
medicines why does he still hang on to
this kind of support even
well it's it's i think it's at least to
to aspects
to regarding what historic and uh it's
uh
he uh received the government from
huawei and venezuela is a poor country
and when chavez arrived he did a lot for
the poor
that's uh what people still are thinking
of
and maduro is i know
not continuing it but he's losing that
charisma chavez chavez's head on on one
hand and he has the hand on the oil
and uh the revenues of oil are are huge
with the us as his first customer and so
he's
distributing it and the higher ranks of
the military
are receiving a lot of those rewards and
so the military is still with them
all right eduardo mendes from dw latin
america we appreciate it